[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
kind of
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on you guys gaming out here
coming at you for another attic show
today obviously uh you know we have a
lot of spicy topics for you man we got
horizon for better west scores and all
the fiasco stuff that's going on with
that we got
xbox wants starfield to be the best game
bethesda has ever made and we got this
cyberpunk next-gen patch that i felt
like was it was it was a joke i didn't
feel like it was real but now it's here
and it's real and obviously i got my
co-host with me hustling over what
you've been doing hustle
i have been playing the game on pc this
it's all the craze apparently it came
out in 2018 but it's an mmo i think it's
called the lost ark i hope i got that
right
i tried that over the weekend cut the
cut the duh
and just lost
yeah pardon me pod mic it's all good
it's all good
i'm a stickler for it i don't know i
love that game
but hold on isn't that a game called
lost
no it's a game called arc that's that's
why i'm getting it
uh
yeah survival game yeah that's right and
you have to dedicate your whole life
to oh no
what that's this is another game you've
got to dedicate your whole life to a
prank no not like arc
art or argument
ridiculous
you're like there's these things on art
that you have to like
you have to like tame animals like these
dinosaurs and i remember dizzy and john
spending hours taming that at dan what
was like we're not talking like a couple
of things we're talking like 15 to 20
hours it felt like like that's how long
and they would have to take turns like
they they would do one and then john
would come in like five hours later and
he would do it for a couple hours like
they obviously they've made a rain
they've made adjustments since then but
it used to be like that
that's crazy
now yeah yeah lost isn't that bad but
they yo yo hustle you you i mean look
you're not the only one clearly it's
well they say they had like uh half a
million people have uh
have uh downloaded and played the game
since it did this early access a week
ago
and i'm one of them too
i got two games i got two characters and
three separate servers
i think um i think i'm just gonna work
on this one server with the
troubleshooters and then we'll see
what's what
what server are you in
alright is it adrian
investor
no no
a-d-d-r-i-n-n-e or something like that
i've i'm okay with the name
it's free to play um yeah you never play
the mmo like myself the only thing that
i've come close to playing is um grand
theft auto and i know that's not a
mmo like you know but this is kind of
different from me but i'm i'm like i
like another attacks and everything's
gonna cool down and they gotta fix the
controller support the second that they
fix the controller support they'll be in
there because i can't i can't type and
do the i just can't do it i don't have a
space for i just wanted space for my uh
arms and hands and stuff so but not but
it's it's cool like you know it seems
like it's gonna be a fun good time and
you know hopefully i won't uninstall it
outside of that
outside of that man i just you know been
on my retro retro mode uh you know we're
talking to a few of the homies behind
the scenes and um
yeah i'm just having fun with um super
mario rpg and that playthrough will be
coming through soon enough after
probably at the horizon forbidden west
which i'll be getting next
then whenever the 25th is whatever that
is i think that's the 25th
uh that that's what some of you guys
next time oh black slap man what's been
going on what have you been playing
lately let me guess been jumping on that
destiny getting weight ready for that
witch queen right is that what you're
doing no
no
absolutely not but no um i actually been
playing lost like hustle uh like i said
i'm on i got six characters on three
separate servers uh i've been enjoying
i'm enjoying that man like look it's
because like there's so many people
that's just like hey i want to play lost
ark with you i'm like oh what server you
want and they're on a different server
than me so i'm just like all right i'll
just make a sir a character uh pick a
class that i haven't already picked uh
skip the prologue and then now i can
actually play with people and that takes
like 10 minutes so i it's not like i put
in like hours of time in six different
characters i've only put in like maybe
hours of time and two
so and and and one of them is my main on
the server that i chose and another one
that i chose what uh the homie elder cat
you know uh cat daddy lurk me and him
been playing it um
he's far far ahead of me at this point
yeah when cat like
when he's when he grinds he grinds
he grinds yes
like he this is this man i was like yo
what level you at
he said 21 i'm like 21.
just got started
so i've been playing that i've been
playing seafood uh i've been playing
more hades as usual i have hades on
every platform um i've been playing mass
effect 3
legendary edition about to finish that
up on on playstation and i actually uh
did earlier today
the
leviathan dlc which is really good and
then i i'm currently doing the uh omega
dlc with uh the uh the vsu with your
help helping uh arya to look get omega
back so it's pretty fun um i've been
having having a good time playing like a
gazillion games as usual
that's what's up so yeah i've been
pretty much playing i played a lot of
seafood i didn't beat it
i look i the game's good but i can
honestly say that like
it's not
resonating with me like other games like
it is a fun game and i enjoy it but like
i got to the third area at like 22
and
i just
there's nothing that really like
gravitates me back towards it you know
what i'm saying like
i feel like
this game is so amazing but at the same
time it's so many missed opportunities
and yeah i guess that does happen with
games that are like i got some questions
though indie devs you know what they
have don't have all the resources yeah
well okay slow-mo have brought up the
point um slow clap
jesus that's gonna be that that's not
confusing at all so slow clap is the
independent developer do you it sounds
like you see a lot of potential in there
if they actually had like a budget
behind by the sound of him
at it you're talking i thought you're
talking slow-mo yeah i feel like
this game whoever funded this game like
i don't know if if playstation just
bought timed exclusivity or they funded
it but if they funded it they should be
ashamed of themselves because
you should have gave these people more
money because they clearly had a gem you
know what i'm saying but it's just like
you get this unique ability where if you
die you age but they don't really they
don't really have a whole lot of
explanation of how you got this ability
they kind of show you but kind of don't
at the same time
you know there's no cinematics in it
whatsoever really uh so like pretty much
the game is rotated to where it's a
revenge story you're going against these
this group of people that did something
to you in the past when you was a kid
and you growed up and now you want
revenge but when you come across even
the person that that tried to kill you
there's no real
like connection of you of you upset with
that person you know what i'm saying you
just walk in the room like one line you
just walk your room you slap your
knuckles pretty much like let's go like
so it's just we when you beat him though
he does say say like i've been waiting x
amount of years for this moment like
yeah one little thing but
yeah
it's subtle but i'm gonna go back
eventually and beat it i'll probably
give like you know
i'll probably do a video on the iop
channel
um talking about the game as it is now
because i haven't played the fourth i
think there's five regions i haven't
played the fourth yeah
but yeah
it's a good game man i just wish they
would have put more
more uh not effort but more money behind
this whoever funded it because like
there's not really a whole lot of
damage that's done on the body either
so it's just like you know imagine what
was that that fight club game that was
back on like the ps2 remember where it
would show you breaking limbs and stuff
like imagine stuff like that
if the game looked better too now i'm
not saying the game doesn't look bad
because it has a unique art style but
right i do feel like if they could have
put a little bit more time and money
behind the looks it would have went
along more way
um but you know
i do kind of feel that the art style was
chosen on purpose
so that it could kind of like
because you know that kind of particular
art style can can last longer than other
art styles like someone tried to go for
a photo realistic look and then like
usually you see developers do that like
five six years later you just like that
don't look very photo realistic no more
but
when you have a particular art style
like when people go for cell shaded
graphics or like a comic book style
thing then like it works like it stays
pretty timeless but um like i was
playing a wolf among us the other day
and that game came out in 2013 and it
still looks good today because it went
for a comic book aesthetic instead of
like for the realism
yeah and i i like that you know that
company came back telltale i always
liked telltale when they shut down it
generally hit me like i was like damn
because i really enjoyed their games and
i'm glad that they're back it's just
like when it comes to see sifu it's like
they have something good they really do
and if sony isn't negotiating them with
with a like an exclusivity on their on
their sequel
i don't know what sony doing because if
that team
had a proper budget where they could
actually make something i feel like they
can make that sony template better than
ever
because that combat is some of the best
combat that's in gaming right now
no more impressive the fact that they
sold 500 000 so quick they they outsold
eternal like damn near immediately
well that's because return came out it
was broken and [ __ ]
i mean
you know still for all intents and
purposes they can't they came in and out
did a you know a triple a developer or
first party developer at that point so
i don't know about like uh sony's
relationship with slow clap uh i do like
they got they have time it's a time
exclusive so they of course they
probably paid them some money to get
like whatever time period it is if it's
three months six months whatever but i
do recall their first game which was
absolver was a time exclusive on xbox
for a short period of time before it
went to playstation as well so
it may not they may not have any kind of
relationship with either platform
but outside of just hey look here's our
game and then and it's only seoul sifu
and was like hey look we'll get we'll
kick in some money maybe the money that
caught that that was your development
cost in order to get this for a time
exclusive time period but yeah i mean
it's going to show up on the xbox
soon and i'll probably wait for them
i'ma wait for that game pass that game
pass
now i'll probably if it comes out on on
on
xbox i most likely will buy it there too
because i do feel like the franchise is
phenomenal uh whatever they do next with
this seafood thing uh even if they don't
make like a direct sequel like keep the
foundation in this game and make
something else like it like you have
a you have something here i don't know
what it is but you got something and it
is imagine the possibilities though
think about this think about that combat
with like final fight or double dragon
or something like that or mortal kombat
like think what like another iep with
characters imagine about with that
imagine if they did
a like a co-op game with that where like
you could do like co-op
fights and stuff like
it's just like i really enjoy it we
don't want to go too much into this but
they need to really
whoever
someone
needs to pick this studio up like a and
and i'm never really vocal about stuff
like that uh people are clowning on me
and making the capcom video that
microsoft my bad capcom like it is what
it is i was i wanted to talk about it so
i'm going to talk about it you know you
guys need to stop trying to dictate what
i vape videos about because you ain't
going to win i'ma win that fight every
single time i'mma make a video about you
guys trying to win that fight but you
still lose
yeah it is what it is so you know let's
let's go on to the the first topic man
you know
let's discuss either
the horizon forbidden west's meta meta
score and the fiasco that's going on
with that
we could talk about star field our
expectations and the fact that
microsoft and phil spencer particularly
wants
this game to be bethesda's best game
where we could talk about cyberpunk man
what do you two want to talk about first
why should we let our guests pick all
right oh you want me to pick
your guest over here sir yes sir all
right let's let's no i think let's let's
get this shorter topic out of the way
quickly i think cyberpunk yeah yeah
let's go ahead and knock that one out
the way people have been knocking that
game out of their their uh their storage
devices on their
on their consoles because i don't think
too many people are going all right so
let's check this one let me set it up
all right for those of you that don't
know
cyberpunk was one of the most buggiest
games in existence that came out uh
they've been they kind of went
underground for a while would you not
agree they went underground well they
really say a whole lot they went they
did exactly what we told them to shut up
and go fix the game they went and done
that um i i have been told i haven't
personally downloaded the patch yet uh
because
i'm still debating if i want to go play
it again but we'll see
so
if you look at it they they i saw the
comparisons there is a comparison and
they said they fixed a lot of
[ __ ] that was going on with that
game
so my question to you guys is first off
have you played
the cyberpunk ex
the cyberpunk update and two
do you think it's too late for them to
do anything with this game
we'll start with uh we'll start with
what's it since
since slo-mo pick the topic we'll start
with hustle
all right
have i have i played the new
bugs and patches yet no i actually
thought i had the game downloaded on my
pc but i didn't actually i must have i
understood this drawing a while back i'm
installing it now as you should
yeah yeah i know i know that that drone
is pretty bad um i got like three and a
half hours and it just wasn't ideal for
me now will anybody care about this
at this stage of the game nah cause it's
too much it's too much that's going on
like horizon about to drop next week
if you're a nintendo fan the kirby game
about to drop in march and so on and so
forth uh you know god award just dropped
on pc uncharted about to come out or
uncharted this out you know what i'm
saying like
nah it's over it's over um whatever
goodwill that they had
destroyed could come out to be a
masterpiece man whatever goodwill that
they had people would get to it once
they get to it if they're like me and
they didn't bother um
you know doing a refund they can still
get the check um if they don't have the
game they can still get it for cheap and
if they didn't do a refund they'll just
play whatever they feel like but like no
i don't i think this brings people back
the good thing hustle is they actually
did like a five-hour demo or something
like that so you could play the game for
an extensive amount of time before you
commit to buying it and it's kind of
weird but considering how long
how long this game is slow mo is that
really
normal practice
like
yeah i mean look five hours is more time
you get than ea access
true but the game like i think when i
beat the game it probably took me
somewhere anywhere between 25 to 30
hours
um when i beat it i beat it back like
what it was like a mess and and i maybe
a good maybe one or two hours was me
trying to get the game to work
in that time period i remember
doing the final mission and there was a
part where there was a tank that was
supposed to like do blow something of a
door up but the tank
was like basically like a paperweight
and every time a bullet would hit the
tank it would flip up in the in the air
and then come down on on its head and so
like when they would do that like it was
inoperable and so like i had to
like spent maybe like 45 minutes trying
to do that one section over and over and
over again and i had to like
my method was to fight the enemies as
soon as they dropped off of their
helicopters away from the tank because
if any bullets ricocheted and went down
there it was a wrap i might as well
restart it it's like little bugs like
that
extended my play time but
i think five hours five hours get it
gives you
the amount of time of the prologue your
your origin story for your
your v
um
the first mission that basically gives
you the plot of the entire game
that's like five hours right there so
like
by the time you're done with your trial
you know whether you like this game or
not and i think i think that's a good
idea for them but i think it was a
terrible idea for them to release it now
i don't think that
this
five-hour demo was really designated for
people if they liked the game or not i
think it was more like look i know a lot
of you refunded it because we know
and i know a lot of you didn't buy it
because of the reviews we know
and i know
our game is considered one of the
buggiest games in history we know
but we got this five-hour demo where you
could you could see for yourself
that none of that exists anymore like
so it's pretty bold
it is it i hope look i hope they bounce
back because
i personally don't feel like
cyberpunk themselves wanted this i mean
cd projekt red i feel like it was a lot
of the executives over there that that
pushed this on oh yeah
yeah if you look at like if you look
into it uh it was the actual developers
were doing everything they could try to
get the game delayed
they didn't want the game to come out
until like would have been holiday of
last year is when they wanted the game
to come out and there it was their
executives that tried to they actually
said they wanted to get uh the double
dip they wanted the last gen console
money and then they wanted the next gen
console money and so like they they when
the console was coming out
for them that was like no we're
definitely releasing this year no matter
what
i do feel like as long as this game is
relatively fixed because i would say
that this
next-gen patch is going to fix next-gen
versions for the most part
you know there might they might have to
do some tweaks after this just to fix uh
some fine uh stuff but i feel like that
the majority of the issues on
cyberpunk's probably gonna get fixed
with this and as long as they come out
with the witcher 4 and they make sure
that game is great
and is bug free or relatively bug-free
nothing is both free when you do these
big massive games like this so the
problem is is when you do these type of
games
here here's the scale
for bugs and here's the scale for for
you know
the enjoyment you have with the game
this scale has to be higher than this
skill
and as long as this scale is massively
higher than this scale you're going to
enjoy like the old bethesda games people
oh book that is the why's everyone give
them a pass because their bug scale is
always like here and their enjoyment
skill is always up here mm-hmm
fall like saying that that's also
subjective because 76 was the very first
game that it was flipped
uh you know uh cyberpunk a lot of people
like cyberpunk but it was very buggy
dying light too i enjoyed dying light
too it was buggy but i enjoyed it more
than i was annoyed with the actual
bugs
it's just like i'm never going to
advocate and
and want these games to come out buggy
i'm not gonna do that i feel like
you
as a company
should do everything in your power to
make sure games come out functional
and what annoys me is it's not even
games that have no business being broken
comes out
like cd projekt red
was cyberpunk okay it was way more
broken that should have been but a lot
of people understand that if they come
across bugs in these type of games that
it's one of those things where it's like
okay i can get it this is a very
ambitious game
but there was way too many bugs uh you
know bethesda game same thing but when
you have
games that you feel like they should not
be broken and you're falling through the
map like returnal
that's when you get to the the mindset
where it's like yo what's going on here
and i'm not saying none of them are
right none of them's right
i've i was formed
playstation pulling cyberpunk off the
playstation store
because i feel like that should be a
standard practice if your [ __ ] don't
work
we pulling it off
hey indeed
it was also because they uh they wanted
you to see
yeah yeah but they they sent out the
messages they told the gamers to go the
sony for the refund and sony was like
excuse me
what what
don't come to me
no you know what well
i i think they should have just kept
their mouth shut but what else could
they really say like they wanted refunds
those games were in those stores like
obviously if it was their own store gog
i think they own gog then that would
have made more sense you know what i'm
saying because they can actually re
issue these refunds themselves but when
it comes to the playstation store and
the xbox store they have no control over
that they're going to have to tell them
those consumers to go to those
prospective platforms that i asked for
the refund but what they should have
done is they should have
communicated with all these stores and
they should have like an open dialogue
where they paid for the refunds you know
what i'm saying like that 30
yeah yeah and i think it was also the
wording of their little yellow you know
these they had always had those tweets
the yellow messages right it was the
wording of it because it was like hey if
you want a full refund of your of your
game
we will honor all four refunds talk to
somebody and it was just like
wait hold up
like
you know it only has a has a refund
policy that's a little bit stricter than
what xboxes is but i can see them like
yo they'll be telling
customers to come to us and we can we
guaranteeing refunds right now like that
that that might not make them name them
right now that definitely didn't go over
well with sony and someone in the chat
did bring up the psn a non-existent
digital return policy they got a pretty
lacking digital return policy and i
think that
was definitely one of the reasons that
there was so much attention put onto it
was because of that return policy
yeah hey i want to respond to uh i
believe this gentleman's name is account
in the chat
hey listen man the reason why i'm
well why leaves a bad taste in my mouth
cyberpunk in general is because nobody
told them to oversell that game the way
that they did
like when you if i did videos on it
because i saw like a lot of stuff saw a
lot of that game in the press and they
kind of made it out to be something that
it you know they knew when they started
working on it let's just say that i mean
they knew when they really saw them
keeping the buck they lied
in the marketing material they were
showing features and stuff that wasn't
in the game
yeah yeah i mean not to mention all the
cut content i mean it'd have been dope
if they would have you know implemented
set code content like having the
third-person vehicles having the
customizable vehicles and stuff like
that if they would have implemented all
that in this update i'm like alright
cool that'd have been dope for them
that'd have been dope to see but um yeah
and look listen i also know this this
this isn't completely um
cd projekt's red's fault you know they
kind of like
were held you know by the i'll say hell
by the high parts by the polish
government the polish government kind of
put the pressure on them they're like yo
hurry up and do this like that that was
certain
oh yeah
something with their laws with like
labor laws and things like that like
paying people i think maybe it was like
the bonuses or something like that they
had to get
uh yeah but i mean look they
here's the thing is that is that their
investors
they have been kind of delaying some of
that stuff for a while because like the
game wasn't ready um but and like in
previous times it wasn't ready to like
previous years it wasn't ready as well
so like i think they could have probably
could have got away with at least give
it another year but they
like they openly came out and said like
yeah we really just wanted to double dip
on on the you know this
transition from one generation to
another and so
you know look they got their money
because i think so like they're saying
14 million in the first month it's it's
so sold a lot but the slo-mo i don't
know if you all remember
just recently i want to say maybe one
maybe two months ago um i don't know
it's not not the young lady not um the
girl who used to be at a playstation now
not the playstation nexus not her not
holly now holly bennett but there's
another gentleman like he did he did a
live stream and they were just asking
different questions and everything
and he
he really thought somebody was trolling
him but the dude was just trying to ask
him like a genuine question about the
game so he kind of barked on him a
little bit and then he tried to walk it
back so there's a lot
and there's a lot but then there's a lot
that they would have to fix in order for
cyberpunk to like i guess they'd be
successful because they're already so
slow you just said they sold like 15
million that first month yo they came
out and said that too and i think this
is the reason why we didn't get uh
battlefields numbers because remember
when they came out and said that hey we
sold this much and this game was in that
condition like there's a reason why um
ea didn't mention anything about
battlefield 2042 because like they were
they went
they were in the back room and counted
their money in quit in secret they're
like
we're not gonna come out openly and say
yo we bro we released a broken game but
we still got that money
right right that would that would not
have gone over well not at all and i
think like you know this did hurt the cd
projekt right in the red name uh i feel
like before this game came out they
actually had a lot of bargaining chips
in the industry i still think they they
still do because they still made witcher
3 and that's considered one of the best
games to a lot of people but this
this as a whole definitely
impacted that you know that that
industry name they had because i feel
like a lot of people
they could do no wrong a lot of people
felt like they literally could do no
wrong it's all i'm asking for man is
like
we just we need to come together
as an industry more often
and
because here's the thing about like
boycotts
most of them don't work
you know
you have a better chance
people say vote with your wallet the
problem is there's too many people that
don't pay attention to what's going on
and they buy [ __ ] that's the problem
even the people who say vote with your
wallet
don't vote with their wallet either
look at something like the look at
something like destiny
bungie has screwed over their fans
multiple times and my dumb ass is still
buying the witch queen on the 22nd
so you know it is what it is but it's
just like you know bungie's a little bit
different because it's a lot about like
the direction of the game it's not
really like broken uh you know features
or anything like that so i do feel like
when a game comes out broken
that microsoft needs to yank that stuff
off their store playstation needs to
yank that stuff off their store steam
needs to yank that stuff out of their
store epic because if this happened
enough times
don't you guys think that they would be
very cautious before releasing games
they would be and you know what they
actually have tools or like like
uh policies in place to prevent this
from happening but then they also they
circumvent their own policies with how
they treat big time developers and
publishers so like so like the whole
approval process when when
the game goes gold and they give it to
sony and microsoft they're supposed to
make sure the game does it isn't broken
and then
and they give them recommendations of
like okay look you know we normally
would not approve this
because you got all these issues and
then like the developer goes to them and
says we'll fix these issues before
launch don't worry and it's always like
it's the trusted developers that get
that kind of leeway like if the three of
us were being a studio and we made a
game microsoft isn't going to trust us
that we're going to fix these issues
before launch but they trusted sydney
project red and they betrayed that trust
and so like you gotta stop giving these
people leeway like that when they they
don't do what they say they're gonna do
the funny thing is i always assume that
like
certification process will protect the
consumers a lot of the times but when i
talk to people that are actually
know what that certification process is
they say it's not as in-depth as people
think
it's pretty much just like does it run
and does it crash our console oh it gets
you to the title screen and the xbox is
still on
out like it's not really like
real
in detail
and i don't know if like an actual
person does it or a program
so i'm kind of curious
exactly how that works
but but even that doesn't work remember
when control first came out
control was shutting down playstations
and xboxes i was like yo so what
happened there
i'm very crazy i'm very like adamant
about my hate for control but i can also
say that
that gameplay in control is some of the
most fluid crazy stuff that's ever had
i've ever experienced in games i love
that gameplay
i think i think quantum breaks story is
better
but controls gameplay i love it i'm not
a big fan of remedy i actually think
revenue needs to like go away but um
after i play control i can actually see
okay maybe i was too harsh on remedy uh
but
they got to deliver something that i
enjoy myself and it's not that i always
feel like remedies games are so out
there
like
i don't know like it's kind of like
kojima because i've always said kojima
belongs in a stray jacket but you know
facts
but but guess what
that kind of mind
makes some of the craziest stuff that
people like i didn't like that stranding
and i don't know if you gentlemen like
that stranding but the cult
following for dead strain look there's
this dude named donkey that's on youtube
he's a big big youtuber
his video on death stranding was
hilarious like
i lost it it was so funny it's just like
look like
i always felt like remedy i know we're
going off the top what's that actually i
don't care i've always felt like remedy
is the prime example
of playstation needs to buy like i feel
like if playstation bought remedy they
could take that studio to the next level
because because they kind of make the
same type of games it's just
i feel like remedies isn't the quality
that playstations is
it's not it's not it doesn't have that
same like cinematic feel that
playstation games have although i do
kind of wonder if sony could really help
them kind of get over the hump because
part of my issues with remedy is how
they tell stories and i know sam lake is
an author and everything right but i
what i don't like with remember these
games is that a good portion of the good
story is in like correspondence emails
letters that you see you find lying
around though show me show me that i
want to see
those events that they are told in
letters on the screen and cut scenes or
or you know in in engine stuff stop like
having me read for like five hours
throughout this game
and and they do that a lot actually kind
of like
gorilla games does that did that with
her horizon zero dawn like like
literally the whole exposition dump in
the middle of the game to tell you the
entire story all that stuff is through
like audio logs and video logs it's not
actually telling you the story i i wish
games would get out of that format and
get to actually this is a interactive
medium
show me this instead of having me read
it you know and i
i don't know if sony would get them out
of that mode or not well it's like i
feel like the talent from other studios
could probably get them in that mode you
know what i'm saying like
i feel like maybe even
playstation
could help
by
getting talent in that studio that
wouldn't be available if they didn't buy
them
for instance i'm a huge fan of destiny i
talk about it frequently
i was concerned what what the future of
destiny was after
this uh
this saga with the the light and
darkness is
and that's like 2024
i was like i think that there's a chance
that after matter comes out and if it's
a success
bungie is going to be stopping all
support on destiny because to me
that studio and what they have showed me
i don't know if they could
if they could support two games
simultaneously like that you know what
i'm saying
so
i do feel like now
since sony owns them and sony needs that
place they they need that multiplayer
infrastructure
even if destiny's story is done
they will fund money to continue that
game
yeah and look it look shout out to fix a
big g in the chat he said didn't remedy
try that with quantum breaking people
complain that's very different we got a
full-on tv series tv show quantum break
like that was that's gone like
like too far in the opposite direction
what i'm talking about is like in-game
cut scenes like the transition from from
you're playing the game to now it's like
it's scripted
back to game play like we've seen a lot
of developers have mastered that very
well so sony santa monica did it with
god of war amazing like
marvelous work with god of war and
having you go back and forth like that
that's the kind of stuff i'm talking
about not full-on tv show put your
controller down go get some popcorn
and sit here and watch the tv show for
30 minutes like nah that's a little too
much
[Music]
um i don't know um i'm not sure somebody
said something in the chat like not
every narrative donald taco said that
every narrative needs to be spoon fed to
you
i probably disagree with that and i'll
tell you why i don't want to be in the
middle of a game and then have to go
search for audio logs and audio tips
they did that in the last part one in
the dlc like i found out things about um
excuse me ellie's mother like do a tape
and i'm like
ah i'm like i wish they would have told
that better and that's i love that game
for the record it's my second favorite
game of all time but i shouldn't have to
go look for a tape because what if i
just didn't go that way and look for
that tape or recording or whatever it
was so now they got to find better ways
and that's been a complaining gamer for
quite some time too like
you shouldn't have to go out your way
for the story itself like yo make an
extra mission and implement the story or
something just do something but don't
make me just run and get this little
table
whatever it is i mean not uncharted
whatever it is and
i'm a horizon forbidden west or um zero
dawn whatever whatever those things that
you know that stuff yeah whatever the
things you got to find like nah just
have somebody say it in the story if you
if you took the time to have a voice
recording like you couldn't have
have more time to just write it in in a
more like
i know cohesive way you couldn't just
put that together somehow like maybe i'm
bugging but just maybe i'm buggered i
think i'm not though i'm not
i think it's very very vital how you
explain a story how you execute
explaining a story and certain things i
do understand from a standpoint on you
know you don't need to fill everything
like people love
the bloodborne games the dark souls
games the demon souls but i don't think
people love those games because of the
story they love them because of the lore
and i think that's a different that's a
different completely conversation like
bloodborne of them have a story
but the
the
the lore and the immersive of the world
is what really draws you in on top of
phenomenal gameplay i don't think anyone
in this chat
said yo we gonna play you know what
slow-mo we gonna play eldery because i
wanna see the story have you ever heard
anyone say that
no
everyone everyone wants to fight a boss
that bodies them 20 times before they
finally beat them that's that's what
they want to do that's that's that's
what the draw is failed and ring yeah
like i agree those kind of games the
story isn't the draw and that and then
like even with uh i would say with
remedy i think they're sci-fi nature um
and
the fact that they made their bones with
alan wake kind of like
lends more towards people wanting a
story that they really resonate with
with them so um i think finally with
control you have a remedy game where the
gameplay is rock solid and amazing but
like i just kind of felt like they
didn't the story didn't really live up
to expectations that you would expect
from like a remedy game
um i didn't think the story was that
great honestly
i want to say this before we move on hey
don otaku it's not that you got other
ways of implementing story beats into
different games you can do it through
like you know uncharted has those almost
interactive cutscenes but they got they
have those set pieces the way you can
yeah i mean like maybe it's a lot going
on but there's other ways that you can
implement story into your game so you
can always do it during one of those set
pieces
i mean it's just there's other ways it's
just you know i don't know playstation
the best station look let's that's what
we're going that's what we're going to
say right now that's that's what we're
going to say
before i [ __ ] you up where am i wrong
all right so hold on sir okay let me ask
you guys a question have you ever played
a game and you got turned off the fact
that there was a lot of reading
oh yes could pass on yeah yeah because
sometimes i feel like when i'm playing a
game and there's an excessive amount of
reading first thing i said yo bro it's
20 22 why am i reading this much
like
especially if if i feel like the story
isn't good like the reading isn't good
like the the way it's written is written
poorly then i'm really upset because
it's just like all right this is boring
at this point yeah
and then i'm like feel like a chore and
then i'm just sitting here thinking
myself i wait for anime not read manga i
rape for the movies and not read the
books like what makes you think i'm a
regio game
but anyway we're going ahead and move on
to uh
to the xbox and star fill okay first off
we're gonna you know i originally had a
way i was gonna wear this i was gonna we
was gonna take this but i don't even
care anymore you know what we're gonna
do man what we're gonna do is we're just
going to talk about star field your
expectations of star field and we're
going to talk about
your expectations and realistic
expectations and keep in mind we still
don't know one damn thing about this
game but we're going to roll with it man
we gonna roll with it
slow-mo
what is your expectations with starfield
absolutely nothing because i can't stand
but those games i have never cared about
these games and and i know some people
in the chat want to be like
burn him at the stake right but look i
keep i have played morrowind oblivion i
played skyrim i have played fallout 3 i
have played fallout 76 i have enjoyed
zero of those games
i just they don't resonate with me and
i'm fine with that i understand that
there are people who love those games
and i'm just in this i'm not that person
and it's fine it's fine that said um my
expectations is this is going to be a
very uh um
what's the guy's name the guy that that
the jacket you know
indiana jones jacket guy what's his name
go on
uh
when that's hot how what
yes todd howard indiana jones jack you
got that tell them
the leather jacket yeah um so
todd howard this is his baby
um
fallout 76 wasn't his baby apparently
this is his baby now i think that anyone
who enjoys bethesda games is going to
love this game whatever it is
it's going to have todd howard all over
it and all the stuff that you guys love
the big sandbox with the generic stories
and the main plot you don't care about
because no one cares and you just go off
and just do whatever for five million
hours y'all gonna get all of that slowly
you're gonna love it it's it's not about
the ending man it's about the journey
and how you get there oh yeah it's a
whole lot of journey
here's the thing okay let me
bethesda games are so important to me
because i remember sitting up
playing fall like new vegas and i know
that was made by obsidian but you get
what i'm saying i'm sure that you know
bethesda had a lot of influence in that
game uh fallout 3 i remember putting 500
plus hours in that game
skyrim i probably put a thousand plus
hours in that game and you know
everything i just said you know what
they all have in common
majority of those games have been game
of the year like regardless how you feel
about bethesda
and i said buckthaster
it's it doesn't take away for the fact
that when these people make a game
that's not fallout 76 and people keep
saying they made fallout 76 no they
didn't
stop it's this company that's making
this game did not make fallout 76 they
helped with with some like
uh animations or something like that and
the whole company got branded with that
look regardless how far the 76 launches
it's another prime example if games need
to get
games need to stop being what games are
the game should have came out working it
didn't it came out bare bones that's
true but i think a lot of people that
play that game now they enjoy that
that's why i do think that we're in the
slope the slippery slope when it comes
to i know we just wanted another tire
but it's okay we went into a slippery
slope when it comes to games as a
service games where
you can't really truly make a games as a
service game without time with the
community to form that into a game that
you want
but the problem is
these companies need to go ahead and
start put proactively putting these
games in preview programs that's on
steam that's on xbox and stop publishing
it as a full retail game that's my rant
okay that's my rant but anyways back to
what we were saying about this that that
the actual main team of of bethesda
you know the one that todd howard
oversees the most
it it is the studio making starfield
they made fallout 4
and you know they're going to be the
ones that's making the elder scrolls
actually i've been told that elder
scrolls is already being uh worked on
but you know
what's going to be interesting is
i feel like this game might be the most
important game
microsoft and bethesda's ever made
because i feel like this game both of
them are just bethesda
both of them
because it's it's going to be those
important game that bethesda made
because of fallout 76 and they have to
prove that
not every game we release is going to be
76 quality but it's also going to be the
one of the most important games that
xbox has ever published and made because
now you would consider the same thing
because this is going to be one of the
first key factors to showing the people
what microsoft's new studios can produce
and i i if if it hits and hits if it
doesn't hit it doesn't hit you know
we're going we're going to talk our talk
regardless but i feel like it's going to
do good because
i trust that studio making the game sure
it could be bad
but besides fallout 76 and i know that's
a huge you know that that's like one of
those things where you have a camera and
like the left side's nothing but dead
bodies and the right sides nothing but
dead bodies but i'm only focusing on the
the part of the room that's no dead
bodies like i know i'm doing that right
here like fallout 76 is over here
fallout 76 is over here but look at look
at straight in the camera this is this
is this is elder scrolls six this is
this is a morrowind this is
oblivion this is fallout 4 fallout 3.
almost all of these games have been game
of the year contenders and do you guys
think it's okay
to
write this company off off one bad game
that they didn't even directly make
hustle
well no no and i do want to answer the
question um
of course next and i'll answer the
question that's in the title of course
xbox wants to scan and be great like
this was microsoft for all assistant
purposes this was their like flag in the
sand they'd be like hey this is the
first major move that we made and we
chose to make it with bethesda bug
that's the whatever you want to call
them when they make the cinematics
purchase so when they got all that
this is the this is their marquee game
this is their well i would say they're
magnum opus but for bethesda in
particular yeah they're going to knock
that out the park after what happened
with fallout 76 now i know it's fixed
now and i know that things have kind of
like regained traction
listen let me first tell you all this
i tried fall off four i was on the ps4 i
tried fallout 4 my homeboy shut up shut
up my homeboy infamous he tried to get
me to play that drink i said nah fam i
said i'm just it just was something
about it i just didn't like maybe it was
the first person maybe it was just the
i don't i don't like probably the
everything it was it was
you know i can't i can't shave
my back
but it was like that dreary surrounding
and that was my first fallout game i
didn't really know what to expect i
don't really do research like how i do
it now but
i said now i'm good yeah i know that i
know but this is based out of maryland
and everything but now i'm good they can
stay up north in that yeah i mean i'm
good i just i might but no they don't
have to knock that off the park like
it's imperative that they do um like i
said microsoft
put 7.8 billion behind not just you know
them but like they're a big part of why
that you know why that process happened
yeah you know yeah i remember once i had
when they all had to sit down until i
had what was like when when fallout 76
wasn't working like yo we came to the
office we came to xbox first came to
microsoft first what's up quick uh big
mad mo in the chat said still red phil
is chopped liver
i'm not saying
chopped liver i uh it's made by i love
that studio i'm not really too happy
with the way that they went with that
direction of gameplay uh but i'm not
going to
i'm not going to doubt arcane until i
play the game but you mean the
borderlands
focus the the loot shooter kind of folks
yeah i i would have preferred them to go
with their bread and butter like the
dishonored type of games the death loops
but you know it is what it is
now that they're making rainfall maybe
this game is going to be gold we just
don't know it's just what i saw didn't
really seem to me that i was gonna enjoy
it but i'm gonna try it because it's
gonna be a game pass shout out to game
pass and it looks it
it just doesn't look it kind of like
reminds me of like a different take on
like
something like a like a fortnight now i
know that seems like a weird comparison
maybe it's just more of like the way the
game looks than anything else but i just
any art direction yeah the art direction
i just when i'm talking about
star field like red fall is going to be
there it is i don't think no one could
say redfell's not going to be there but
i think we can all agree
that
people are going to red fall my bad my
bad red fall so i think people are going
to gravitate more towards something like
star field than red fall and i'm not
saying red fall isn't an important game
i'm saying in terms of what these
studios that microsoft built i think
when you look at something like a star
filter that takes off the park it's
going to really validate a lot of things
now if red fall takes off that's going
to be
successful in other areas because it's
going to show that
you don't have to be just a bethesda
software to succeed arcane regardless
how you felt about death loop i enjoyed
death loop it was a good game and i
think that that shows that that studio
could make games and i you know i've
said it multiple times it's funny that
people feel like just because this
studio bought something that they're all
gonna be just they're just gonna start
making
crazy
like horrible quality games and i don't
think that's the case here no they they
are they're allowing them to do what
they want to do they have that creative
freedom to make those kind of games i i
i've said this many times before but
i'll say it again like i don't care for
with that but that's the in-house games
but i am a fan of bethesda's the
published games arcane machine games it
software i am a fan of those those
titles and
like the whole the whole borderlands
field i'm a massive borderlands fan so
for me red fall i'm far more excited for
red fall than i am star field so it's
because you have like red holes
to me look
like people are attacking me for my
fortnight thing like you can attack me
all you want i'm gonna say it again
fortnight red fall look it's just
because i don't like the direction is
that like i see
kind of like
them trying to like sprinkle some
some hero shooter in this game maybe
it's because i don't know what it is can
someone show me a link showing what this
damn game is well like no one has seen
gameplay but like
there have been testers that have kind
of come out and said some things about
how it plays and and i remember seeing a
list of like bullet points and
i thought it was borderlands based off
of the character archetypes that are
very much like borderlands that when
they showed in the trailer but
all the bullet points were saying
borderlands borderlands borderlands all
over the places borderlands are vampires
and like for me i'm like well bet
because i love borderlands i'll
i'll play the hell out of that
but you know i know that's that's going
to be hit and a certain demographic you
know that's not going to be the same
people that care for starfield though
those kind of people they like other
kind of games than that kind of game so
yeah i got a question let me get this
super dress real quick so we got a final
super chat from 108 dragon appreciate uh
one away one away it's a very passionate
person man i love one he's family star
phil will not fail because uh so much of
a following be but it will be
scrutinized because microsoft purchased
bethesda the telescope review as always
i will agree with you i think that you
know regardless even people did that
with leading edge bleeding edge was
literally almost out the door and people
play microsoft for it so i definitely
understand that but then we got a two
dollar super chat from dawn otaku arcane
borderlands that sounds great to me oh
he likes your reference from borderlands
i'm not going to say this game is going
to be about i'm just saying i need to
see more of
how the characters interact with each
other and how more how if like this
co-op experience works before i'm on the
red fall train
when you um because we haven't we
haven't seen any gameplay and i just
took a moment to look at the trailer or
re-watch the trailer um i had saw which
with you guys during the um xbox summer
game and showcase yeah i i understand
the fortnite thing
um this was the game i was excited for i
must have got this one confused with
the other back for blood there we go i
think i got that one confused with back
for blood but
you know um okay so you guys have a lot
of history with like arcane do they
typically just make first person stuff
do they make third person stuff
everything they do is first person for
the most part
yeah no not right it's not rising i
don't know why i thought i don't know
why i thought you said a completely
different game yeah
uh this i don't know why cyberpunk
it is what it is my mind is so messed up
today yeah it's all good no um
damn it cryotech they made dishonored
they made death loop um uh
they made prey i didn't know
what was what was moon something the
moon
the the expansion they did i remember
the moon shot
moon moon uh
launch i can't remember the name but
that was apparently really good the way
that that one played out but yeah
everything arcane does is first person
okay well
you know what i'll try and i think it's
that's for four-person co-op i don't
know why i thought it was five-person
co-op at first because they had the
little robot dog eating or whatever i
remember saying that too but i like the
character designs in red falls they look
really good i like the characters that's
why i said ella that's not in third
person to me like to me
all but all those characters are
different that's why that's like an l to
me though like but i i just gotta wait
no okay you're reading the name in the
super chat because you know oh
i i'm not doing this again no i know
what it says um
no no it's seafood
seafood
x initiative with the two dollars super
chat be crazy if star food was better
than mass effect don't tell that to
slo-mo we gotta
be crazy because that's never going to
happen that's what this is
super chat from
otaku they mentioned third person in red
foley it's pro
the game looks like a third person it
does look like a third person i it's an
elephant if it ain't in third person
that's an elephant i'm just saying i'm
just we got to keep it
you know
i think you know shout out to karl griff
is just one you know i think they need
more
uh experiences in a third person
perspective uh i i don't really
necessarily care that much like i've
never been the kind of person like if i
want to play those third-person
over-the-shoulder experiences i got a
big bulky playstation i can i can commit
murder with over here on my desk oh my
gosh
all right
i got that i don't necessarily need an
xbox to play those type of games i want
experiences different experiences on
every platform i do think they need a
couple i will agree with cog there they
need one or two really good ones how
about they say that
thank you
i think it might be a mix of like if you
choose first person or third person i'm
going to end the we have a private shot
here right i'm gonna throw in here
the a link to some screenshots
okay um for you guys to take a look at
real quick
and uh these screenshots show first
person and third person it could be
third person in like say
um the hub area that these kind of games
have but then actually first first
because like with
an actual gameplay of the screenshots
they're all first person were you
holding your guns and stuff so
i'll throw that in here real quick so
you guys take a look at that i'm looking
actually looking for the uh
the actual like uh bullet points that
was talking about like
yeah what the testers had played
yeah
um but those are i'll find that in a
little bit but yeah um it's definitely
a lot of
we'll bring this up a little bit like we
ain't got really a whole lot to do man
like we got one topic that's probably
going to get through pretty fast and
we'll talk about some red fall from it
because you guys are going at me a
little bit too hard i don't like it i
don't like it so we're gonna talk about
red fall for a couple seconds okay so
here is the screen that they are
bringing up
these are the
the screens let me go and switch to
translation so there there we go all
right so
here's where i fall down
it i i like the the overall screen now
keep in mind for people who say like
this is how a game is going to look it's
not how the game's going to look i've i
play games in alpha that look
dramatically different when the actual
retail version comes out
they don't do a glow up on a game
they're still working on they don't do
that to the end yeah like you know i i
like so you see skills up here map up
here missions you know hustle we might
have went over this in the past but
we're doing it again
uh so uh we got the arcade i don't know
what that is uh so you know he it looks
like it's got some kind of uh
system in it to where it's like
legendary exotics or whatever they're
called one right right um
you got armor
med kit is that remnants what is that
i don't know what that is remnants
they definitely have that the typical
color system of a lot of luther shooters
where gold is like legendary purple was
like rare
blue would be like
standard and green and white you're like
you know doo doo like you don't want
those ones
you like to start a weapon kind of stuff
you know slow-mo and you'll appreciate
this
the layout of it does remind me of
division two
and for what it's worth
yeah i wasn't the biggest fan of the
division two but i'm having to hold you
just me and the troubleshooters was
kicking it and we was playing that and i
think i paid ten dollars for it and i
might have gotten like 20 good hours out
of it i had to go back and check through
the ubisoft thing but i got a nice
little amount of playing time up out of
that um as long as it says third person
red phone has third person for me
then i'm straight because
there's that one screenshot wish there
is third person but
if you go to the next tweet the next
tweet is like all like actual like
screenshots from game play and it's all
first first first person yeah
yeah
that it is first anyone
maybe you could switch back and forth
yeah that's what i was thinking that
that's might be a possibility
and don't you love these names like it's
just like they
like they could name better than this uv
beam mo1
likes
it's it's kind of crazy i think uh if
you look like the textures already in
alpha this is this might this is
probably gonna be a good looking game
yeah looks like the entire wall back
there that that's like that's just the
placeholder kind of thing like that wall
where's his loot zoo like like oh it's
just the placeholder until they actually
put in real assets there when the game
is ready to to really get closer to
launch um i i did do you guys remember
there was talk that the game might get
delayed
um i did hear about that
i mean considering how we haven't seen
any game actual like running gameplay
and it's supposed to come out this
summer yeah i can definitely see a a uh
a delay happening
look at the end of the day man you know
i think red falls gonna appeal to the
people red fall pills too here's the
thing
we need to have this this conversation
real quick man
bring up zoom so i feel like i'm talking
to you guys individually all right there
i could see you guys
we need to stop having this mentality i
have it myself because i'm known as the
added world but that's okay because i'm
okay i've accepted my my flaws all right
it's it's those people that ain't
accepted your flaws we need to stop
having this mentality that we need to
push our
taste in games on every game
playstation gamers now everything has to
play like uncharted i'm sorry i'm gonna
be real with you i will agree that
microsoft needs that's it dude
you're gonna ignore him i will agree
that microsoft needs more games that's
like that style but not yet yanking that
style but we can't act like every game
needs to be like that i've noticed that
there's people that refuse to play first
person because it's not third person i
think that's a little bit of that
playstation bias in people
let me go ahead and um get these super
chats
uh
so we got a two dollar switch out from
don otaku they mentioned third person in
red fall league okay i think i read that
but just the case we got to find out the
subject from donald taco it ain't an l
if it ain't third person ps fanboys are
the only ones who care
okay i literally just said that we're
gonna keep moving past that we gotta
find our troops out for uh
cipher poll 92
we should appreciate bethesda bringing
for uh variety into game pass for the
different demographics plus i trust them
to deliver a good story regardless i i
think that's uh subjective i think a lot
of people like but that's the games for
their gameplay more than the story but
that's just me
all right i agree with that too
hold on why are y'all getting that stuff
together i just want to say this
i don't got a problem with first person
games but i got a problem with all of
your games the first person that's it
like
the vast majority of upset games of
first person that that'll get boring to
me i'm just saying this you know what i
mean just so you say that but i have a
problem with nothing but all third
person on my on sony like
i i i see because the games like destiny
halo i grew up with these games i like
dishonored i i i liked death loop i
talked mad [ __ ] about death for like six
months and ended up liking it go figure
but we're gonna move past that but i
like these games i like the game play
the opportunity i like first person i
think there's a good way of doing first
person but the problem is
is sony has raised the bar on that
immersive thing when it comes to third
person so much that i don't think the
first person people can realistically
fill that gap anymore uh i actually
thought that
cyberpunk did a good job with immersive
technology immersive moments in in in
first person games like here's the thing
like
little things like seeing your arm open
up a door or like when you get on like
when you lay on that platform on senior
pro you actually see yourself like
rotating yourself around the table stuff
like that really helps me with
immersiveness in first persons but like
if i play first person and you click
something and it literally just puts you
in the chair without you physically
seeing you get in the chair
automatically what is this
and i think that
first person does got to do more things
and i think they do gameplay but i don't
like third person
out shoot gameplay out shoot like i
don't like none of that that's whack to
me
that's fine i'm like third and first
person i i'm i'm a fan of both although
probably a little bit more first person
because i you know i i i'm i'm a halo
kid you know i gotta give you a call
i know i'm good i'm good i'm good with
that i got like a thousand hours in
destiny i i think i i think i'm done i
think i'm done
but no um i i i mean uh uh hustle you
talking about how like you
you don't really like it when it's like
all first person but like bethesda
that's like 90
more than 90 percent of their games are
all first person perspective games it's
software with doom uh dishonest first
person machine games with wolfenstein
like all those but that's my point
though
yeah but that's my point
they got kids over there for me like you
know what i'm saying i understand but
there's a
lot of first person now there's a lot of
first person there's the whole lot of it
that's like them
there's a lot of first person but i do
feel like they have sure they have a
massive majority more first person than
they do third but they still got third
person games for you they got hellblade
gears the new compulsion games in third
person uh oh yeah
yeah yeah
indiana jones is going to be a third
person well i mean we can't just hope so
i hope so i think they already confirmed
that that's going to be a third person i
actually got good
i actually thought it better be third
person it's indiana jones
come on yeah i don't know i was talking
specifically bethesda's in the max do a
lot of like first person i know like you
know xbox game studios in general has a
a variety there like hellblade
definitely and and we'll see a lot more
of that with a lot more of their studios
um undead labs with state of decay all
that stuff is third person perspective
you know like you you're gonna get a
massive variety out of xbox over the
next two or three years with the numbers
most likely that's a third person
there's no way that's first um that
better not be first person oh my god
uh gears you know they're going to make
another one hell blade they're you know
they're going to make another one you
got
that roundhouse studio i don't know one
of the bethesda studios hasn't made a
game yet i don't remember which one i
think it's rhino studio but they got
like a mobile game a division over there
so that might be roundhouse i can't
remember uh
i actually thought that perfect dart
should have been a first third person
i thought they should have made that
to like a stealth action adventure very
cinematic story game
i agree with that well that's why i
wouldn't prefer it you know a little
while ago and and i don't know if he was
just pulling thoughts off the sky but
kiss move actually i don't know if he
started that roman but i do remember
hearing that from him that the coalition
was supposed to work on perfect dark
obviously now we know that i think i
made that thumbnail for him
okay all right cool so okay so i'm not
just bugging out on my mind but i
remember but i do remember him saying
that and i was like well damn okay
oh someone's like
what's up perfect artist first person
with third person cover shooting see
that's still whack though
all of it should have been just third no
i know i like the first person to third
person
uh cover shooting but at that point you
might as well just give people the
option to be a third person like
wait so okay i'm trying to wrap my head
around that how does that work so like
you're running around in first person
then you go into cover and then you you
see like it zooms out and you see your
character and you're cover shooting
and then you leave cover and you go back
to first like the first person
i don't like that at all
keep in mind that is the chat you know i
don't know the individual uh you can
give me a link uh but we always when it
comes out of the chat man we got to be
real with you we got we got to have that
disclaimer we got the info from the chat
because i don't want no one going to
twitter and saying addict says that this
is a first person and third person game
so if you're gonna say that you
definitely need to put at the end that
the chat said that not me
so i mean
we're go we'll come back man like you
know because because i told you guys a
couple weeks ago i have some plans some
changes that's gonna happen to the uh
the attic show i'm gonna bring the attic
spotlight back too so you know that's my
spoiler cast with games
uh so you know keep a lookout for that i
don't know what we're gonna do with i
don't know who i'm gonna do it with but
i don't know when i'm gonna do it so
don't ask me none of those questions
because you're gonna get the exact same
thing i just told you i don't know but
it will come back eventually so let's
let's go on to the main event of the
evening i definitely butchered that
can't do that what's his name says all
right so
first off i want to talk about a couple
things horizon
style
first i want to talk about uh after i
lay this out hustle i gotta go get
something to drink my throat's going so
you sure you take over uh first thing i
want to talk about horizon forbidden
west
what is your ex
are you guys excited for the game second
thing i want to talk about
is
the
attacking of the metacritic score from
the 89 to the 90. i want to go over that
tell exactly how you guys feel about
that and the third i want to talk about
is what hulk put up on twitter that i
didn't know
that they're trying to finesse people
out of ten dollars have you guys seen
this
no i have not like
supposedly and hogue is on his stuff so
i'm gonna i'm gonna deem it facts
because hope said it but
it's if you pay for the 59.99 ps4
version you get a free upgrade to the
ps5 version but if you buy the ps5
version it's it's uh 69.99 or
70 bucks yeah so hogue's pretty much
like
you can literally buy the ps4 version
and upgrade to the ps5 version for no
cost so they're trying to take the
misinformation they're trying to low-key
extort people out of 10 because they
don't know better
so let me go get something to drink you
guys talk about the we're gonna start
hustle and i'll be right back
yeah okay so in terms of excitement for
the game
i look forward to seeing what gorilla
games has to offer
you know from the first one anytime you
drop a game or anytime that you would
make a not be for the first time no it's
not gonna be necessarily perfect but
what i would like for you to do is have
an opportunity to fix whatever was wrong
in the first game in your second game so
right yeah i i am a little bit excited
for it um i was going to get the two did
you beat the first one
no sir i got it on pc through my lot
through the melodic punk i just haven't
played it yet so i'm not i don't know
nothing about i don't know nothing about
the story what i know about it is is
that it looks really good and i just
know that she was the outcast because
you know that's from what i played in
the very beginning she was outcast
neighbor star rockstar and all that and
she had to go through some type of
trials or something and that's about as
far as i got and i and i'm not even up a
cabin for this joint like one of them
well you know jack move jack move made
the america they both made the like
comparison like oh this is more like
uncharted with i guess with everything
that was going on in the second trailer
let's say okay well i love uncharted
that's my favorite you know uncharted 2
is my favorite game of all time so i
said let me just go ahead and try this
one out now i was going to get the 200
collector's edition as i was about to
mention but nah
now i'm gonna get the 70 version man
because if i don't like it
i'm taking that joint right back they
ain't going with the statues and all
that if i i can't i can't return to the
whole thing so
next well not the 18th put on the 25th
hopefully it won't get spoiled for me
but i'm a cop there i'm a cop the
physical version there but um you slow
what you tell me dumb did you play the
first one and are you excited for the
second one um i have beat the first one
on pc i attempted it to beat it and
could like there
i i'll tell you about my issues with
horizon zero dawn is the reason why i
didn't complete it on playstation 4 when
it first came out um it was at 30 frames
per second you already know how i feel
about that right now yeah i hear you
yeah i i don't mess with no 30 frames
come on now come on now
now on pc
i played it uh i was able to power
through the the boring part of it and
that's where like one of my issues with
gorilla and horizon
is that
it's a good story but it's a good story
told poorly it's like it's
it has a uh a story pacing issue and it
introduces you to this great world and
all and it gives you all these questions
in the beginning like what happened to
the old world what happened you see
these derelict buildings
no spoilers but like but like it doesn't
answer those questions until like 15
hours in and then it's like 12 hours
before uh uh in between that of
tribal irrelevant nonsense and it's just
like i don't care about any of this
stuff that's going on i don't care that
a loy is an outcast i don't care about
any of that like get back to the story
and when it finally gets back to the
story it is good
and it and i think for a lot of people
if they
get to the part where they explain who
she is and what's really going on and
what the actual issues are with this
world a lot of people will be invested
in it and continuing it and being like
man i'm really digging this but it's
just getting to that part is the problem
so what i really hope will forbidden
west is that their pacing of the story
is improved where i'm not you're not
waiting like 15 hours in to get to the
parts that are really interesting with
the story um
aloy something i don't think is going to
be based off of the reviews addressed i
think aylor is kind of like a just a
character
who's just there there's very little
like development character development
for her herself like she's just
like there are there are times in here
zero dawn where i'm just like i want her
to be like who you think you're talking
to you know not necessarily like like
you know getting like an attitude you
know snapping their neck on them but
just kind of like hey hey like yo don't
talk to me like that don't like i want
to see something some emotion out of her
and a lot of times she's just very much
like oh hi that's how you feel great
okay yeah i'm glad i helped you i'm like
stop like
give me something else out of it like
she's she's boring
and i i think with with she is she is
but i'm hoping with forbidden wes that
we get a little bit more character
development however well unfortunately
i've seen some reviews that kind of feel
like that's not happening um
i'll see for myself but i am hyped for
this game because i really enjoy the
gameplay i really the game is beautiful
the first zero dawn is beautiful this
one looks for forbidden west looks even
better
and
i'm just really like i can't wait to get
my hands on it and play it my for myself
but i am concerned about those areas
that i feel like gorilla has like a
weakness with storytelling and a
weakness with creating like compelling
characters you know you know slow-mo um
and then before you go on
um i can't remember where i saw but you
know
horizon zero dawn had the decimal engine
and as we all know with that stranding
regardless of where fans of it and that
um they went to help kojima and his team
out with the with that during dev
stranded i saw i saw a few things the
way they was like hey they picked up
some some new tactics some new
techniques so i'm i'm more um and i'll
be more impressed with what i'm gonna
see on the ps5 and i want to see if it
can really push the ps5 technically to
his limits um when it does come to pc
slo-mo you already know man like hey
you already know what type of time i'm
on when it comes to that so i can't wait
i just can't wait to see it
yes sir yes sir
the superior platform sir go ahead oh
indeed indeed
and the main reason why i bought this uh
the 65-inch lg oled and sitting in front
of me right now was the play horizon
zero dollar 200 i think i'm talking to
jay barry on twitter about that like yo
that's the main reason why i bought this
joint like because i know how like
technically like beautiful the first one
is and you know like i'm gonna run
through it um it's about it says about
it's about 20 hours and i won't get the
game until the 25th so i'll probably
just stream the whole thing but you know
you never know but
i'm gonna run through it if um i've
heard a lot of things about the first
one that merck said it was pretty boring
but you know mark is you know he's due
bro so i mean we'll see what he know but
merc's not alone a lot of people kind of
felt that way like after you get about
two or three hours in you're just like
you know what what is what is what is
going on here like yeah but i one other
thing that just popped up that i kind of
feel like i hope that he addresses some
of the like the side quests
are
should be more of a main quest instead
of a side quest or the rewards of some
of these side quests should be
taken out
and made to put into a main quest for
example in horizon zero dawn there's a
side quest you do it's so completely
minor
it you could just run right past this
and not even realize it but the side
quest could actually upgrade your spear
and to do more damage and it's the only
time in the game where you can upgrade
your spear to do more damage why is that
side quest
that should be
like either the reward for that side
quest for upgraded damage should be put
to a main quest or that side quest
should be a main quest because you
shouldn't have a player potentially miss
out on upgrading doing melee damage
the only time being able to do that in
the main story i think you could if i
recall correctly you can upgrade your
spear again in uh
uh forbidden in the uh expansion
yeah but like the only time that i can
do that through a side quest that i
could just run right past and just not
even know that that was that important
it's just like they gotta do better with
that so hopefully they do that too
yeah so yeah it is what it is
at the end of the day here's how i feel
about horizon the game
never really appealed to me like i never
really
i tried playing it a couple times i'm
gonna go back and try playing it again
because i like the world and what's
funny is i'm working on a video
that's pretty much like because i feel
like competition's key
and i do feel like
when it comes to
microsoft they need to have more answers
to certain playstation games now
i i was sitting here trying to
make the video i'm like well what can
microsoft's game
be that could kind of compete with
with this game on certain merits and i
couldn't figure out one game uh you know
as much as this game doesn't really
resonate with me i can honestly say it's
a very unique type of game that i don't
think can
could really have a lot of stuff going
it's just you look at it and the fact
that it's got robot dinosaurs in it it's
got uh an okay story from what i've been
told
there's nothing really like it out there
yeah yeah i do agree with that like the
the dynamic the way the combat is so
dynamic with the animals and
and
the
like the animals these machine animals
that act like like
herds or like actual animals will act
where they're just kind of like grazing
in grass and stuff or when they get
violent how they'll rush you and and
all that stuff is is really really
interesting and that not really done
before in any other games and the way
that they implemented it i like that
uniqueness of it and i like
the different animals that they have
with like snakes and all kinds of crazy
stuff going on and forbidden west like i
can't wait to get into that like that
kind of stuff is what i think it really
is a huge strength of that game
yeah you know um i'm anticipating
underwater combat as well i haven't seen
too much on that i just remember her or
excuse me i just remember a lloyd
swimming through trying not to get
caught but apparently you can uh have
combat on the water you can defend
yourself underwater
so what do you guys feel when it comes
to
let's talk a little bit about the
metacritic score did you guys talk about
that while i was gone
no all right so
it got a 89 i think it's still sitting
at 18. i don't know i ain't look today
uh probably not gonna look again i don't
care but
when it comes to the 89 a lot of people
was upset it's not a 90.
and i was reading some of the responses
and some are valid you know people were
saying that multiple outlets are saying
it's better at every
at every corner but it's still the same
score
so i get that
at the same time
i do feel like when it comes to sequels
i don't know how you guys feel about
this
but i do feel like when it comes to
sequels they're going to be criticized
more than the original
because they're going to want to see
improvement in every aspect they're
going to want to see the game kind of
evolve to a different level
but they're also going to want you to
keep close to the original foundation
that the game was built on that's why i
don't feel i i feel bad for for devs
because in a lot of ways they can't win
so how do you feel about that
uh well i want to say 89 is an amazing
oh yeah and they should be
everyone at gorilla should be proud of
whatever metacritic score they got i
can't stand metacritic because i i kind
of feel like it's it's way overrated and
overblown and i hate that there's so
much focus on it but i know there's so
much focus on it because developers and
publishers sometimes their bonuses are
tied into it and the reason that is
because there are plenty of people out
here who
who will make the decision to try a game
out based upon what his metacritic score
is
and that's unfortunate because i kind of
feel like people should choose what they
play based off of what they see and not
what other people tell them
all that said
um
i think that the people who are upset
in most of the playstation fanboys who
are upset that horizon forbidden west
does not have a 90 meter critic or only
the the console warriors who wanted to
brag about yet another sony game with a
90
meter critic score and that's the only
reason they care
that's the only reason because honestly
at 89
if
if it had a 90 does that change the game
you know what it is nearly one point you
know what it is slo-mo i feel like
like extreme playstation fanboys they've
lost a lot of narratives that they used
to cling on to they lost the sales
narrative the power narrative and in a
lot of ways they've lost the game's
narrative and it's not necessarily that
they don't have the better games but
they used to be able to hardcore going
to xbox they can't necessarily do that
anymore so yeah xbox i had some great
i just wanted to say real quick continue
they had some great like scored games
last year like they're not a single one
that was below 80 right so
yeah like they can't really say that
about xbox the metacritic score things a
lot is what a lot of them have left like
they're the 90 plus and they feel like
if they can't go on twitter and scream
and put that 90 green symbol that says
must buy on there like they're going to
lose something like look
at the end of the day i have been
i've read that there's
some bugs in the game like nothing like
dramatic dramatic but enough to
infuriate you like
they knew when they put that game in
there there was those bugs in there so
they got what they deserved like if you
want a 90-plus game have a 90-plus game
don't have bugs
if they didn't have bugs they probably
would have an id plus game right now
because
when you're on that 89
standpoint that high eights
and if your game has bugs you might not
hit that 90s because of that
yeah it's very true a lot of games have
uh hey look you know um
very famously
obsidian missed out on a big bonus when
bethesda was publishing uh the fallout
new vegas game they were making and that
game had a massive game breaking bug
with like load screens if you i think i
i i think it was like if you walked into
enough rooms and it did the low like it
would eventually get to the point where
the game will have an infinite load
like year like hours and hours into it
and then you couldn't play the game
anymore um there was that kind of bug
and
they ended up with the 84 they needed
the 85 to get their bonus like that kind
of stuff can definitely like get dinged
and i think justifiably so because the
only time i really care about reviews
is well i want to know if the games are
buggy messing that i don't care about
their opinion on the game i you
typically i'm sold on the game well
before the reviews come out but i want
to know if the game is a is is a buggy
piece of trash because if it is that
that's the only thing that will prevent
me from playing it is that
it it's going to be a chore to just get
through it instead of the game's
difficulty i'm i'm fighting the bug's
difficulty like i don't want to do it i
don't want to deal with that so i'll
play something else you know
yeah when it comes to the metacritic
thing um
i kind of when i do research for that
it's not for a number per se it's
literally just to see if they can
improve let me never say this before
it's to see if they can improve on the
first one um in terms of story and
everything that's subjective so no
matter what y'all would tell me or
anybody in the chat no matter what y'all
would tell me i would have to experience
this for myself um i was joking around
and saying that you know merc told me
that this game was kind of boring
i'm gonna play through it and we're
gonna see but the way i've taken the
story is much different from the way
slo-mo addict merc and whoever else does
yeah we got to find out superstar from
gaming forte slow-mo speaking facts
sorry couldn't make it had an inventory
tonight oh no worries man no worries
worries boys
[Music]
what happened to that phone call this
morning told me you couldn't make it man
yeah yeah
and i i texted him and i caught i
appreciate him saying i'm speaking facts
as i as i tend to do uh yeah but no uh
uh i called you forte
i left a text message man what's crazy
forte is you could pick up
you could do
mad podcasts at home but you can't pick
up a phone and say yo i can't make it i
i'm busy got i got stuff i gotta do you
can't do none of that no i'm joking with
you slow-mo you you you have a good day
of your inventory man
so uh you know
at the end of the day like
what i want the most is i just want the
the game working
and there's a little bit of bugs with it
so at the end of the you have to we they
have to deal with that
because when you make a game and if it's
got bugs like i said you can't really
expect a hundred percent of every game
review because i never understood why
game developers
send out
patches after the game's been reviewed
like and if they did if they you do get
the the
the retail
patch that's that launches with the game
it's like a couple days before the game
comes out
so like you've
realistically
probably beat the entire game without
this patch
and i just i don't understand that
mindset like if you want the game to be
reviewed at its best you need to have
that patch out before the reviewers play
the game
yeah so we gotta find out the subject
from grand c
uh that's also a labor issue though devs
need to uh utilize and stop companies
from trying uh from tying their bonuses
to medicare 100 percent he's not wrong
because
i would be upset i would be upset if it
was about medicare because medicaid
could easily be manipulated some people
will make lower scores just to get the
most clicks
and not even not even that though addict
like the only thing with metacritic that
i really don't like is that some
people's opinions are way heavily more
than others which yes i never really
this ain't no shadow ain't no
organization or no company
but ign's word shouldn't mean more than
the game spot the game spots words
shouldn't mean more than like a level
one or minor you know i mean like no
problem i understand the thing in the
industry and you know i just do our
names out there just to
just to have other people's for you know
just so you can draw an example from but
when they come to like those easy out
like uh easy ally still in the industry
i'm not sure but like when it comes to
stuff like that i feel like they
shouldn't
i feel like i feel like it should just
be an equal thing right also
you're right it's a weighted average
they and i actually posted that on
twitter yesterday because i was like i
saw a lot of discussion about it and i
was like look
metacritic sucks man like they do await
average you're right uh hustle what what
they do is like ign's word and their
number
is is
worth more in the average than say level
one gaming or or you know like the the
log net like
because they they consider them a
trusted we we've we've been doing
working with them for so long
silly what's crazy is medicare it's not
easy to get onto like
they say oh it's trusted we trust these
people
like you go through a pretty like crazy
mentality to get all the people that's
review on your site so you don't trust
half of them you wait let's be real
it's gaming politics it's gaming
politics that's what it is and it's just
like until
like france's dying light too
they had an embargo for media and
embargo for influencers and that made no
damn sense to me you know what i'm
saying like it's just like
people need
to
what's funny is you have very few
companies but i do see a shift that
people are starting to lean more towards
influencers maybe not the industry yet
but definitely uh like consumers people
watching videos on youtube but you know
yeah it is what it is when it comes to
the the the metacritic score i i do i do
see metacritic as a valid tool to use
with the how the industry feels about a
game because regardless if a couple
misuse it the majority of you use it the
way it's supposed to
so
you look at a game and it's an eight
nine nine uh mid eights early age you
can relatively see that's going to be a
good game and you should try it but if
you look on metacritic it's like a six
and a five maybe you should stay away
from that game like right right
also one other thing i don't like about
is how they
they do their averages with
outlets that do the five-star system so
giant bomb and venture beat yeah
five stars
or something like that
right so like like if say there's a
review from giant bomb and they gave a
game a three out of five and then even
in their blair review if you read the
review they're mostly positive about the
game and they feel like it's an average
it's a good solid average game
that's a 60
on right on on metacritic and it's just
like that's not you're not representing
what the outlet really felt about that
game i don't understand why they just
don't like look if you want to be our
website you have to have a one out of
ten ratio like i don't understand how
that's hard
yeah yeah it is what it is so let's move
on to the last
part of this topic the ten dollar ps5
tax what i like to call it man the ten
dollar hold up
the ten dollar we're going to activate
your playstation 5 controller tax all
right
so
first off like we were saying before
this you know if you want to play the
playstation 5
and you buy
horizon on the ps4 you can actually get
a free upgrade to the ps5 so you can
literally buy the ps5 version that's 70
bucks for 59 99.60 on the playstation
store so what i'm asking you guys is
first off
why don't they just make both 60 at that
point and do you think that's a little
sleazy we'll start with hustle first
yeah actually i mean because there's no
if
if what hog if if what he's saying is
true and i'm on his twitter now and um
i see his thumbnail it says
don't buy horizon forbidden west on ps5
if that's true and hogan really never
been like a liar he never lied and never
jumped out the window like that before
why would he start now he wouldn't um
you know this this is horrible it's kind
of horrendous man and
this was a controversy back then because
you this was like the first game i think
the way horizon when they said it was
coming out they was gonna have to pay
the extra ten dollars at one point and
then playstation go back on that it was
like oh you don't have to do that no
more and now it looks like it seems like
that that r so i'm not really sure but
but i'm gonna be real with you at it
um i'm gonna call jack move johnny i got
ocd on my nerves back if i'm gonna get a
ps5 game i'm gonna get a ps5 game it's
gonna go right next to this it's gonna
go right next to it it's gonna have the
same spine then it's going to ps5 on the
spot no more ps4 stuff is coming in this
house i'm sorry i'm sorry i don't know
how people feel about it but i just know
i pay the extra ten dollars for the
cover oh i'm sorry that's that's just
how i get down i'm not no sony fan boy
but
y'all look look at it it's white it's
beautiful it's not
it's not blue normal it's not blue man i
don't know like no it's it's horrible
for real and then not to be ashamed of
myself for buying it but
it seemed like if i bought a ps4 version
it's going to do like probably what
i'm probably what uncharted did like you
probably would have the uh availability
to upgrade it to the ps55 version but
that's digital i don't like digital
stuff
oh okay okay i see what you mean
it's a physical thing yeah yeah and if
i'm and if i'm gonna pay for a physical
version let it be on ps5 i know i
shouldn't head extra 10 but i'm paid i'm
not gonna lie let's be real here this is
them
take advantage of the m4 on playstation
uh people go with a ps5 and see ps5
version and just assume that's the
version they have to get they're not
expecting that they can buy that version
and get an upgrade for free
i think it's wrong man and you know
what's funny nobody's talking about it
nobody
i i bet you will see podcasts after
podcast very few people will talk about
it this week i haven't really seen no
media cover it like it's it's it's crazy
the amount of stuff that this company
gets away with like so much
anti-consumer stuff
attic that's because we confuse the
message and i think everybody's confused
about it to be completely honest with
you like just
it's it's a whole lot going over there
going on over there playstation and
you're right the media should cover this
more it's just like but
what's up i just feel like when it comes
to playstation
like
xbox would get a lot of like they don't
get a whole lot of highlight of stuff
they do but when playstation does crazy
stuff like this like i feel like it just
goes over everyone's head no one really
talks about it you know in a couple days
it's over like i'm not saying that like
ten dollar like let's be real here ten
dollars isn't a lot of money it's not
it's the principle behind the matter
it's like look like i shouldn't have to
pay ten dollars like i've said on iop to
use features on a playstation controller
that you showed me marketing the console
and it's just like it's ridiculous like
i don't care about the ten dollar hike
like charge seventy dollars like i don't
care about that like i'm one of the
people that i don't want it to happen
but i understand if if i'm paying three
extra dollars
for some soda at the store for a 12-pack
why do i
and we paid for we paid 60 dollars for
for gains for like 15 years
so it's just like look if they want to
raise that i don't want them to but i'm
not going to like really attack anyone
for a while but it's just like if you
bought games on the ps4 they just need
to naturally give you the ps5 version
and then what's funny is this is just a
temporarily thing because sooner or
later people are only going to buy ps5
versions so they're getting all this bad
publicity which like you know we just
really focus what kind of bad policy
they really get no one's really talking
about it but they do get some bad
publicity like big atlas do cover it
from time to time and sometimes they'll
cover it and then it'll just go away in
a couple hours but they're getting all
this type of bad publicity for what a
couple years of gaining ten dollars on
games
what they're doing is they're training
they're training the playstation
community to accept seventy dollars for
games um in the future when ps5 when
this they're just putting games out on
ps5 likely after this year because we
don't know we don't know of any other
ps4 games that are that they're doing
first party beyond 2022
but um i've always said this i've always
said that pr uh value is subjective
um what i what what someone else would
pay for say a
uh sports game nba 2k
uh i wouldn't pay a dollar for nba 2k
because i don't care right yeah yeah but
um but like but if if they were selling
it for a dollar that's a major steal for
people who love that game if square enix
came out with a chrono trigger remake
i i don't i i shut it to talk about like
what price i would pay to play that like
it would be far above what the normal
price is because like so all this stuff
is always subjective like you have to
look at it and be like is this worth 70
dollars to me um
in regards to her this situation i knew
they were going to do this
i knew that when they when they came out
and said that uh we will honor what we
said before about giving a free upgrade
for horizon forbidden west instead of
just making it as addict said just 60 60
bones across the board
they're still doing 70 for the i knew
there was going to be some tongue full
over here i knew there was going to be
because like i actually decided let me
go ahead like oh i'm already getting the
game let me just jump on playstation i
hear that you can pre-download it let me
jump on here on my ps5 get that
pre-download going
i go into the store and i'm like wait
hold up so which one is the which one is
the the the ps4 version
i'm not giving them ten extra dollars
for what right so like which one and i
i've been all digital for forever so i'm
like i'm trying to figure it out i just
decided you know what
i just jumped on their web web page and
just did it from the web page instead
and so it's just like the fact that i
had to do all that i i was just sitting
back like they really tried to get a
brother they tried to catch me catch me
laughing you know
i'm sitting here
and really if you know you if you know
what the actual
free up that you can get a free upgrade
all you got to do just make sure
whichever version you put into the cart
is the verse that says 60 dollars
but the fact that the fact that they put
i think they put ps4 and ps5 on both of
them
so it's like for both the ps4 version
and ps5 version when normally when if
there's a ps4 version of a game it just
says ps4 it doesn't say ps5 there so
it's just like that kind of foolishness
is like i know what you were doing there
you you decided let's confuse some
people and maybe maybe they won't know
and
maybe they won't realize that they
bought the wrong version or maybe like
as as you guys have mentioned before
that like they're completely uninformed
about the fact that they're supposed to
be a free upgrade and they just don't
know
that they could have got it about that's
a lot of people yeah there's gonna be a
ton of people like that yeah the vast
majority of people who buy this game
other millions who will buy this game
aren't going to know the things that we
know as the hardcore gamers and people
so saying like the deluxe edition come
with both i'm like why do you need both
like if you buy yeah
like
yeah yeah this is pointless yeah oh i
didn't want to say this though um we
mentioned this about the metacritic
thing right heavy is the head that
weighs the crown attic you're right
we probably won't hear an ig well
i won't be clicks to stay in my platform
we may not hear another major outlet
even speak on that
but even if they just go on go out their
way to clarify what could be going on to
the average consumer because like i
ain't for the whole i've been keeping up
with a lot of it or just making it
explaining it like what
you need to get what you don't need to
get like
i mean they might i'm not gonna say our
like companies aren't making these
articles i'm just not seeing them yeah i
mean well okay well just just say for
the sake of argument let's say they're
not let's just say that they're not
being responsible let's say they're not
doing that but
i probably
had it out the back of my mind because i
wasn't even gonna get the 60 or 70
version i was going to spend 200 on it
uh i think i told you that before the
podcast or maybe at the very beginning i
was gonna drop the two on it for uh
collector's edition i ain't about to do
that now though but i will go and spend
the seventy dollars which
man look ain't none at that gonna say it
right slow-mo earlier in this
conversation you said hey i think you
said starting next year will be the
cutoff date for yeah that's the way it's
looking because they haven't announced
they're going to announce more games
this year of course but as of now they
have now not announced any games outside
of 2022 that are going to be ps4 they're
going to be on the ps4 that's first
party well slo-mo i just agree with that
and i'll tell you why like it's still it
might not be difficult
for us to get a ps5 but it's difficult
for the average consumer it took me a
long time
i would sit in those queues over and
over again no luck i i really had to
struggle for my ps5 and if it wasn't for
kid smooth selling me his ps5 i don't
think they got another one
and you know and that's that's the other
thing that we really gotta like be aware
of
we're gonna see the
the stop of ps4 because they're still
making ps4 then they actually announced
that they were still gonna be making
ps4s so
god of war um
i got a feeling index four major ips is
still being when they assume that they
drop in the next two or three years
whatever they announce for naughty dog
like the new ip that they're supposed to
be working on that probably might be the
first one you understand what i'm saying
because
like just this generation first of all
this generation is going to be i have a
filler and just prediction got my
fingers crossed whatever i think that
this generation is going to be a repeat
of the xbox 360 and ps3 and wii due to
the semi-conductor shortage i think it's
really going to be that because you
can't find you can't find nothing out
there you can find nintendo switches out
there oddly enough you can find those
well i mean the the hardware in those is
so outdated i mean
but you can still find those but know
what would basically ease so you can
still find them but the ps uh the the
new xboxes you could probably get you a
series s but you can't get a series x
easily you can't get the ps5 digital or
physical easy so yeah i mean this is
it's going to be it's going to be
hearing something here let me just say
that but i think it's going to be about
eight years so so you think like when
they do their conferences or maybe one
conference this year whatever sony does
that they're gonna when they announce
new games they're well one they won't
announce it because they you know how
they they how they did their one
showcase where they they only said the
way they phrased it everything was ps5
and then later on we found out those
games are going to ps4 as well but you
think that at some point we'll find out
like whatever new things they're
announcing we're going to be going to
ps4 as well oh one thousand percent what
that and and this is but that's it's not
their fault it's just it's the worldwide
shortage they
they can do about it and like people
can't really get upset behind it either
like
the wild thing is that remember like was
it a year and a half ago maybe two years
ago when when everyone was getting on
xbox for saying that they were
supporting last year for two more years
they're now no longer supporting last
gen red falls and star fields are only
xbox series games everything else that's
coming out for xbox first party well
maybe not if this activision deal goes
through then that probably will change
for them because you know how they are
with call of duty that thing goes on
everything until like the stuff that the
wheels fall off your console but um
everything else is going to be all you
know current gen it's funny how
like
people were just acted like that was the
worst thing in the world you're holding
the games back you're holding the devs
back oh man now it's the complete
opposite it's pretty funny yeah i do
understand that you know when it comes
down to this it's just like playstation
do better or that that's pretty much the
only thing
really could be said it's like look if
if your people because i personally feel
like all this is doing is punishing
early adopters
so it's just like you punish the people
that supported your brand from the start
like i feel like that i feel like
there's a smack in the face man i really
do but you know
that's pretty much the whole show man
but you know what let's go ahead hustle
what is going on what what what are you
doing this week
well outside of the the family stuff
that we spoke about behind the scenes
you know helping help my people with
that some family stuff hopefully
i would say i would like to say next
week i should be back on somewhat of a
consistent schedule streaming the
youtube stuff definitely gonna come back
up uh it's gonna be some retro stuff
it's gonna be some new stuff gonna be
some old stuff gonna be some new stuff
i'm gonna you know i'm gonna take some
different uh chances with my channel i
just wanna have some fun we just spoke
about character bios and all that stuff
before so
i'm getting all that together and i'm
just just running um i will be playing
horizon zero now like before i you know
get the second one
so first and foremost man we're gonna
see if it's boring and that says about
23 24 hours to beat so i'm gonna make
sure i run through that
and and that's what i'm on this week um
addict how about you kind sir well
before we get to our steam against it uh
so
slow-mo what what's that podcast that
you be doing
how about that what's that podcast
oh yeah i do i do have a podcast yeah
yeah so a damage per second podcast with
the homie gaming forte we do that we
trade all back and forth between our two
channels every week this week is going
to be on gaming for today's channel it's
thursday nights at 9 pm eastern uh we we
it's a two-man show usually every now
and then we'll get someone else in uh
addict dropped in um on us uh last week
we talked about seafood with us for a
little bit but usually just you know the
dynamic duo doing that thing much like
youtube guys here and uh we have a good
time so yeah come check come check us
out this thursday
and then uh i you guys know where to
catch me every sunday at 1 p.m eastern
uh you know the iron lords podcast in
the same channel you're currently
watching this on definitely uh go
subscribe to the gaming attic channel
i've been put up videos i'm going to put
up a video tomorrow probably going to
make some people mad but it is what it
is i'm used to that
uh definitely go to the iop twitch
channel because now i'm starting to get
a lot of the stuff finalized with that
um we had to really find out like what
we wanted to do with that before we
actually committed anything to it so i
got all that took care of so we're
probably going to be picking up twitch a
couple days a week playing games uh that
you guys like i do want to make a state
of decay video so i'll probably stream
twitch over there for a little bit and
uh take the
gameplay and figure out what kind of uh
content i want to make on on that so
that's probably
sorry that's probably what i'm going to
do there i'm going to stream get uh
because i want to start making videos
dedicated to certain games like you know
what they could do what they can't do
why i didn't like it just you know
general ideals in general so definitely
follow the twitch channel uh hustle has
put it in the chat a couple times so i
appreciate that hustle and uh you know
follow us on twitter man uh you know
mine's uh lord addict iop hustlers
hustle and motivate uh exactly how his
name is spelt and uh slow-mo is exactly
how his name is not i'm pretty sure i'll
put them all in the description but
definitely go uh follow us on twitter uh
probably in the next channel yeah
probably here in the next couple weeks
we will be
uh redesigning the aisle uh the the lord
ad
oh my gosh the
the attic show artwork will be probably
done so hopefully that will be done and
uh you know i appreciate every coming
through man we have like 200 like 80 90
people here at one time definitely that
like button when you guys leave man uh
you know appreciate the outcome it was a
great outcome let me say something
before we go uh
if you don't mind y'all make sure y'all
follow slow-mo backslap follow gamer
forte as well but you make sure you
follow slo-mo man
slo-mo
you know
just like family reunion to me man
no no but you've always been extremely
insightful in terms of your content man
and
that that needs to be pushed a hell of a
lot more um not these you know and that
you don't know i got i got a i got a
very very interesting video coming out
this week it's going to be about uh i
i'm just i'm trying to i'm changing up
my content just a little bit right and
i'm doing the video about hair and games
okay um and in particular black hair in
games
as well and how sometimes the the
quality of the the hair these these
characters and games is is a little
subpar compared to everything else and
like it's gonna get deep into the
process of how hair is made
in video games why it isn't as good as
it is and just a lot of different stuff
and things that i've tried out and
actually tested out myself so it's going
to be pretty in-depth i'll hopefully
have it
done within uh maybe tomorrow or the day
after but yeah yeah okay well we look
forward to that for sure man for sure
definitely definitely yeah so it's like
i said i appreciate everybody coming
through man uh you know what we'll see
you next week
uh hopefully uh you know i'm gonna get
slow in the back with forte because i do
want like that dps and i feel like
that's just i would have loved to
we'll work on that in the future i do
have a couple more guests i i'll
probably try to keep it next week or
just me at home so i'm trying to to
still maintain this is a dual show like
we're not having